hey everybody it's Jesse and site is
almost ready to launch today is going to
be probably the most random video I've
done because I'm just trying to handle a
few changes that came in just today just
clean up a couple of things that I
noticed when I was testing so I don't
know if this ever happens to you but
sometimes things just come up at the
last minute so we got to try to try to
get them fixed you can see my my Trello
board here you got a lot of stuff in the
done Colin have some things in the to do
column still and a lot of these are
color-coded now the kind of dark grey
color means they're on hold they won't
make it in before launch the yellow I
don't even remember what I named these
on hold okay so the grey is the dark
grey is if time allows which at this
point we don't have time so they're all
going to be after and then the other
ones are on hold for for some some other
reason maybe I just haven't made up my
mind about whether I want to actually do
them or not so most of these things in
this column at this point are not making
it in so the only column we have to
worry about or this one in this one the
last thing here is the point to domain
to the server so obviously once that
happens the site is launched everybody
guessing people saying hi in the in the
live chat and I am still sick so
yesterday I was sick today I am even
more sick than I was yesterday so I
apologize in advance if I'm a little bit
all over the place
the truth I've been having trouble
focusing today I I keep forgetting to
reset my Pomodoro timer and so it's just
been weird so I'm trying to have some
take some energy drinks and things like
that
just try to stay awake and be alert
enough to do this so you all helped me
out today if you see me doing making
some crazy mistake please call me out on
it
Thanks unless I get well soon thanks
hopefully I will hopefully after the
site launch this I won't be working
crazy hours yesterday
when I left yesterday I had already put
in a whole week's worth of time
according to my normal work week and it
was only Wednesday so that's probably
not helping my illness that I'm working
all the time but yeah so after today
today might be late again but after
today I should be able to relax a little
bit and hang out with my family all
right so let me tell you what I was
working on you got me right in the
middle of a Pomodoro session so I tied
my thing so I have about 6 minutes left
in this session I'm working on this
adding a hover effect to the menu so one
of the changes that was requested let me
bring this over so I can show you one of
the changes that was requested was to
let me bring this over because only that
at some point I was will bring it over
now was to add a hover effect to the
menu so before we had nothing nothing
happened when you hovered now I have a
little hover but here's the problem
there's always a problem this seems like
oh this would be so easy so there are
several problems one was the way I had
set this up these allies they didn't
actually cover like the whole height of
this so when you hover it was just this
tiny little rectangle that
make getting colored so I tried to
change that up a little bit so I got
that it was basically editing some line
Heights and padding not really big deal
which is kind of annoying tedious stuff
so I got that sorted and now I have this
issue so right now this this works right
it looks okay it works but when I scroll
down it no longer works so uh luckily I
remembered what was going on with this
menu so I know why it's doing that
so let me show you I need to make this
bigger sure that you'll probably can't
see this so basically what happens with
this menu I away too many things open
let's just close something though but
all we really need is is sticking out
and app dog is and and the styles okay
so basically what I tried to do was use
this JSX style thing I don't even
remember what it's called officially um
it's part of next well it comes packaged
with next I think it's just JSX or CSS
and JSX something like that but
basically it lets you write write in
your component if you can see here you
can write all the styles so it gets
applied here but it's scoped so this
this is locally scoped to this component
so these styles won't like lead out on
anything else on the page which is
really cool you can make a
self-contained component and assuming
you're not overriding anything with your
other style sheets you can actually just
leave it named you know whatever you
want so I just you know I just put ul
here because I know it will only affect
this ul I don't have to worry about
putting a long string of like I did here
which is the only reason how to do this
is because I was already using it like
this in the main stylesheet and I don't
have time to go
through and clean that up yet I'm sure
if you work with CSS reading like the
time you know how this is that at some
point it's just easier to to do this
than to try to find where everything is
especially when you're short on time but
really what will happen is once I if I
can get all the styles moved into here
then I can just take it out of the main
style sheet that will be fine but here's
the problem
whenever let me go in the JavaScript to
show what we're doing with a stick
enough so if you can follow along here
we're actually cloning so this long
string of jQuery things is actually
cloning that menu so let's go back and
see so when I scroll down the original
menu has now just been hidden you can
actually see a little bit because the
the Styles change you see the padding
changes slightly in the hover is gone
that original menu gets hidden in a new
menu that had been made and hidden
originally that had been cloned is there
so this is an entirely new menu that was
created on the page look or at least
whenever that function got called which
in our case isn't necessarily the page
load it could just be the navigation and
it's a client-side navigation so there
is no page load so we initialize that
and component did mount if you're not
familiar with react you probably just
didn't follow what I said don't worry
about it check out some of my previous
videos and I explained it a little bit
better or or check out the documentation
on component amount so of course all
this that I did here that I was trying
to do things the right way the react way
this doesn't work because this is
locally scoped to this this particular
component that component is already on
the page with all the styles
ready before the clone one is even made
so I have to go back now to the main
stylesheet and edit this anyway which if
I had been lazy to begin with I would
have done it this way to start so now I
have to choose this foot so just small
annoyances then I mean I'm going to
check the live chat again
depending on how many people are
watching I may just keep the live chat
going for longer than normal because I
mean I'm going to be here until the site
launches I'm not I'm not going anywhere
I may have some interruptions just some
other people that are working on content
for the site my boss so I may take have
some breaks but there's a lot of there
are people watching and you think it's
it's useful then I'll keep going for a
while I think it would be cool to keep
going to actually launch and we can see
it hopefully it it doesn't break in
front of everyone but but that's that's
the plan and it will help me to stay
focused and awake if I talk to you all
while I'm doing it and Mike so my timer
just went up for my Pomodoro session so
I'm not going to restart it right now
we're just I think I can get this done
in about five minutes and we'll just
count that as one session since I I just
talked for the last six minutes okay so
we're looking for bottom nav and let me
go back to dev tools and Sewer that
alright so looking for line 380 okay so
here we are alive 380 so the first thing
I need to do is grab this and make it a
hover and this all the indentation is
crazy because this was a personally
written in SAS and then compiled so this
is not normally how I indent everything
this is just how it comes out from the
compiler and then I'm just working in
the CSS right now because I
set up the compiler to compile sass so
normally I guess I would set everything
up alright so we need to add a hover on
here and let's grab this all we did was
just change the background color and
there we go and so this is just our main
menu color and then I just I think this
is the light property I'm I really don't
know that much about color formats but I
just changed this to make it a little
darker alright so now I guess we could
take this out because I mean I would
like to have it in here but because it
clones it there's it's never really
going to work unless I come it I don't
know maybe it I could rework it but I
don't think it's going to work so now we
need these scale bottom now if you ll I
a so let's add in these styles so you
see at this at this point this is not
super difficult we're just it's just a
matter of finding where this is making
sure we we're getting the proper
cascading so we're not do anything
special like I said changing my and I
change in the padding we added a little
a little transition effect I recommend
adding a transition every time you're
doing something like like a hover or
some type of change it makes it look so
much more smooth otherwise you get this
really kind of abrupt change and it's
just kind of jarring doesn't look as
nice I that's fine bottom now view oli
line height padding actually we can
replace both of these padding things I
don't know I had to there I never
cleaned it up
so as I've been going along I've been
trying to get rid of as much as I can
over here in the main style sheet and
put it all
into the components it's kind of easier
to do it as you go along at some point
I'll probably have to just go back and
make like a deliberate effort to go
through and move them all in but that
can come later and then finally we have
on the UL we just change this margin and
now we can get rid of this completely
let's make sure we don't have any inline
styles and we don't okay so this should
work now I'm going to save this and this
let's go back over here and I'm gonna
refresh because the the hot module
reloading doesn't work on my stylesheet
it just works when I update components
all right so this still works good and
now this works now um it does it kind of
looks a little bit squished like I want
more padding up here let's let's do that
I'll do that now that's kind of thing
that I probably won't remember to do
it'll just slip through the cracks let
me actually I just heard some some
messages come in from my boss okay
okay he's got some images for me to put
on the site there was there are still a
lot of images from like the old old
original site that just wouldn't were
they most of them just weren't big
enough where they had the wrong
dimensions for what we're doing with
this site so my boss just said he has
some images he asked if he could upload
them on it on his own but I don't really
have kind of like the content management
system for the site is WordPress but I
don't have everything linked up so to
save time I've actually been hard-coding
some of the sections basically the
sections that you know there's not a lot
to them and they're not really likely to
change
I'm just hard coding for now and then
I'll make custom post types and
WordPress so that other people can edit
things on the site without having to get
on the server or edit any code but at
this point the sections that he has
images for I don't have connected in
through the WordPress API I didn't make
post types form yet so I guess we'll be
uploading some images here soon
once he sends them over okay some of you
guys are asking some questions about
JavaScript libraries yeah okay so I'm
using my like framework is materialized
so it's a material design it's like
bootstrap but with material design so it
comes with JavaScript and CSS and it
requires jQuery so that's why jQuery is
in here normally um normally you
wouldn't you wouldn't want to use jQuery
with react and I went over that in more
depth I think in my like two days ago in
my live stream so but we are using it so
there's just a few things you have to do
to make that work and there was one
other question let me see Oh someone
wants to know the Chrome extensions that
you're using um am I using
what am i using in chrome uh
this one let's see this is WP sniffer it
tells me if it's a WordPress theme
this one is live reload right is it your
browser sync this is live reload okay
and that works with like what I'm using
gulp I think maybe I don't even know if
I use this one anymore be honest with
you that might have been left over from
when I use grunt on the time ago JSON
format err so this is this one um is how
I get the JSON to look really pretty
like that instead of like this which is
pretty unreadable most of this is
Google's Google Drive application
launcher which I had pretty much never
use on right there LastPass saves all my
passwords and stuff definitely recommend
that super useful wocket time keeps
track of all the time I spent in my
editor and in my in my browser and then
every week it sends me an email and
tells me like how much time I spent
writing CSS on this time I spent writing
JavaScript HTML unless time did I spend
in chrome so it's kind of cool to go
back and track things this is really
useful this one I don't remember what is
cooked but it tells me what this site is
built with what is this tampermonkey
lets me do custom scripts that I can run
on certain URLs that's why my github is
black this one lets me know if there's a
retired jazz if there are
vulnerabilities in any of the JavaScript
libraries that are being used usually
jQuery always comes up on there I'm not
sure most jquery versions it seems like
have some type of vulnerability and
full-contact for gmail this just tells
me when somebody emails me it has links
like automatically gradually to their
social media profiles so i can check
them out
okay another change all right so I just
got another change from my boss he says
the whole behind the titles need to be
more opaque okay that's going to be an
easy change so we will do that but first
let's look sort this padding out I said
this is going to be forgotten easily and
it almost was so I want to try to do
this in a way let me bring my dev tools
over all right my dad tools are super
small let's bring this up a little bit
I'm gonna bring it up too much because
it's going to mess up how this looks as
well I think this did I know it didn't
awesome
I thought it was going to make this guy
get bigger too but it didn't so alright
so I want to try to do this in a way
that I don't have to edit everything all
over again so let's see if we can make
that happen
let's go right to the a since that's
what's getting Harvard if we can
increase the line height maybe let's
just check up the ladder a little bit
and see what happened okay alright well
that kind of did what we wanted but we
didn't quite get let's see didn't quite
get what we wanted let's check these
allies let's see if that did anything I
don't think it did
my night 16-14 yeah let's make them the
same just to check but I don't think it
did what we wanted
no it did not let's try it on the UL
increase the margins that's not what I
want this is what I was afraid of more
complicated we thought let me refresh it
I can just reset back to what we had
originally yes somebody in the light I
remembered with that Chrome extension
was this one that tells me um wet lap
eliezer yeah super helpful
I always seem really smart whenever
someone was talking about a site and I
tell him like exactly what it was made
out of made from and I think people
usually think I can look at the code and
tell that you can't sometimes but I
normally just use this plug-in all right
so my boss is knocking on the door I
will be back in a minute this is the
same thing in the worst ways sorry so
sorry again that text yeah pretty mean
you know how or who can do like the yeah
so on about the images for the forbidden
no no sections looks like a vertical
image also some of the text is tall now
changes to this may not be well yeah
depends on the bright so no there be
places where it could be like tall image
on the desktop and just something that
happens later on the desktop horizontal
it could yeah a little stack on the
mobile yeah so it'll get a little kind
of the way I think okay I choose
preferred
a surer image on mobile so there's no
scrolling right that's what I mean
something like I add it back the
anechoic sorry portrait on the desktop
another landscape um have a show
focusing no worries even if at least for
now me other images and even if they
just go away okay all right thank you
okay I'm back that was my boss and my
boss is super super helpful a number one
it's awesome that he lets me do these
live streams but also he handles all the
content stuff for me so when it comes
down to times like this no one I don't
have direct interaction with a lot of
people everything goes through him which
is awesome because I have less
interruptions in general so that's great
and he handles all the content you know
like usually people will give him like
books of content which obviously we're
not going to put all that text and
everything on the site and then he will
go through it and kind of edit it down
to smaller chunks that are better for
the website and they give it to me so
that's that's super helpful and then
there's another guy that is like amazing
at photography and image editing and
things but he's on vacation this week so
I had to do some image editing myself
earlier today just some basic stuff so
that slowed me down a little bit but I
don't think that that guy's taken a
vacation for the entire time that I've
been working here so he definitely
deserves it which I mean I've been here
for like two years it's not that one all
right so where were we
oh this menu trying to get the padding
so we just reset it because I kind of
messed it up this this might get put on
the do later list if I'm going to give
it one more go and if I can't fix this
quickly
then we're just going to put it off
because there are other more important
things that need done before
we launched hopefully the I'm still
waiting on some content to come in and
that's always a little it causes trouble
sometimes I had one section that I spent
a ton of time on the site doing and then
we changed the content and the size of
the section totally changed and then
everything I'd done didn't it didn't
look right anymore
so hopefully nothing like that happens
again font size when fiddly padding
maybe we'll just increase the padding no
not that padding this better let's hear
that the okay oh all right I think
there's my word let's increase the line
height let's go to 16
it's a too big um it's not bad all right
now let's look if we can increase the
padding maybe this will do it let's see
yes it seems to be working if it's if
the screen is too small or blurry for
you right now I'm basically just
hovering over and dev tools that element
so I can see a little outline of where
the padding is and I'm just clicking my
my keypad up and down to just kind of
see exactly where that needs to hit it
looks like seven pixels is where needs
to go I'm gonna have to add some top
padding and I'm going to guess four whoa
okay I see I have all right now let's
check it out oh man what a great guess
it was for exactly I remember when I was
just starting out there was a guy that
worked for the same company that I was
doing some contractor work for and he
used to be able to just look at a
website and say yeah you need to put
three pixels of padding on the top of
there and that'll fix it and you'd go in
and that was exactly right he just was
so good
knew exactly the number of pixels so I'm
pretty pumped that I just did that
because I always thought when he did it
it was awesome a nice that works so now
let's make sure we'll just copy this and
that that worked out as good as I could
have hoped only had added two lines one
element so super happy about that
let me check will worry on this about a
uoy a and the line height and padding
that saved it give it a refresh just to
check no servers down and I mean if
you've been with me for the last week or
so you know that for some reason I keep
getting errors on my development server
it is the air has something to do with
the hot module reloading and I keep
putting off actually trying to debug
that error so I just have to restart
occasionally that the thing is like the
restart only takes a few seconds so it's
it just hasn't seemed worth it to me to
do this these aren't really broken it's
just like a cords issue since I'm one
local oh so these actually do work on
the main site if you all want to check
out the site while I'm working on it you
can inspect the codes up on github and
the test site link it's up to so those
are both in the description so you can
check things out if you see something
crazy this just looks totally broken let
me know I mean I'm I'm not trying to
rope you guys into being testers for
free or anything but if you would like
to test things out and let me know
that'd be awesome I can't guarantee that
I can fix everything because you saw my
list obviously I have things that need
done but it'll probably get on the list
all right so let's pop this in this was
about one my my tracking of my prayer
yes the time has been slightly less than
accurate lately because I just there's a
lot of stuff coming in so I'm going to
I'm going to actually start up another
Pomodoro session so we have a 25 minute
timer so we will try to track this this
is going to take probably three minutes
increase opacity of tile overlay so
let's check this out in dev tools so
here's how we're doing this we have a
background image let me make this bigger
this is probably still too small for you
okay so we have this background image
here and the first is this actual like
squid Lee thing literally it's it's
names clearly I didn't name it like that
I got it from the the old site but I
like the name and then we're putting a
comma and we're doing a linear gradient
and so it's basically like we have
double backgrounds and the linear
gradient is the same at on the top and
the bottom I think this is top and
bottom so basically it it just looks
like an overlay so what we'll need to do
then is change change this these fives
and dev tools freaks out when you try to
edit this it's all in one big line so
I'm just going to edit this in the in
the code because it'll actually be
faster so where is that right now okay
so I do actually have that in the
component so let's grab our title
component which I don't think I've
opened so we have a component for title
and by using alright so I have these
yeah this looks strange I know and
that's a whole nother story as to why
that had to happen like that
oh that's things that's kind of crazy
why do I have okay I needed a global tag
all right let's
where we had there we go alright so
let's pop this up I mean there's no
reason why we couldn't go to 75%
capacity here it won't block that much
of the image so I think that'll be fine
now that should reload there we go all
right yeah that's a lot better that
should be that should be fine I'm not
going to waste a lot of time trying to
fine-tune that that works let's check it
off and move on the lowest unit I ever
count is a half upon Maduro which would
be twelve minutes and fifty another
twelve minutes and thirty seconds
um that took less than that but we'll
just round up and Boop's and we'll move
it to done all right let me check the
live chat quickly oh you guys are having
some good conversation here yeah I'm not
going to be as attentive to the live
chat just because I got to get a lot of
this stuff done so I'm sorry about that
I will Oh on I'll look at the live chat
though like after the site gets launched
I will look through it all so if you put
some in there I will see it I never
totally ignore it
[Music]
let's see someone says Team Rocket in
there you got a Pokemon fan I wish
Pokemon with my kids so I am familiar
with Team Rocket oh man looks like we
get we got a fight going on in here
whoa all right so I don't really have
time to moderate anything so I apologize
if anyone is being rude to other people
um I don't I just don't have time to
look and see like who should be blocked
and you know who started what so yeah
and there's some messages in another
language that I don't know
okay yeah this does need moderation so
yeah I don't really have a moderator I
know there's a way you can assign
somebody a moderator but I never had to
do it before um so anyway whoever's
fighting please stop and otherwise I'll
probably just block everybody who's
involved in the fight I don't want to do
that but I just don't have time to do
anything else maybe in future uh future
shows somebody if somebody wants to
volunteer to be a moderator or something
as long as you're cool about it and
don't like block everybody that I'd be
happy to make somebody a moderator but
yeah I mean just be you know be cool I
think everybody just needs to take a
breath and relax all right like I said
some of it's in our language I don't
actually even know what people are
fighting about okay I'm not going to
work on this one there when when content
came to me it didn't have actual dashes
it had like double hyphens instead so
someone commented that I can't can we
get rid of that oh yeah definitely but
I'm not even going to attempt this until
I get all the content in because I might
actually like fix this in content that
is not going to be on the site so that's
let's hold off on that let's do this
Oh Magus I need more info because I'm
waiting on text info so the color will
just let me know that I can kind of skip
over for now add squiggly things all
right let's have these squiggly things
let me show you what we're talking about
and I mean let me do a commit real quick
I don't want to get too far ahead about
committing so what did we do a hover
effect - sticky Neve yeah that's what we
did I definitely did more than that
because of that I'm seeing the events
page got changed - I can't remember what
it was so that's going to be the kivett
message that's less good to commit
frequently you know you see at this
point I can't even remember what I did I
also I'm not sure if I'm using the word
effect properly if it's supposed to be
affected with an e or effect with an A
I've been using it with the Eve
basically for everything during this
project for all my commit messages so I
can't ever remember my wife's actually
an English professor so I don't know
better I I just rely on her to proofread
all my stuff and then I end up never
learning the grammar rules myself
alright let's go to the home page so
we're going to work on I got a request a
few hours ago to add these little things
in to some of the headers I'm only going
to do it on the home page some of the
interior page headers are just way too
long and I don't have room for these and
they wrap up onto another line and it's
going to look really silly if one's like
up here and ones down here I don't
really want to do all the CSS work to
make sure that they always stay out here
so this is how I did it I originally
wanted to do these as background images
but this h1 or h2 spans the whole width
so it's a little bit difficult to get
them in this position especially because
I'm this font size will change to
slightly depending on the screen width
so I just didn't want to get into all
that so I decided to just make two spans
within the h2 so this is an image that
I'm loading in a span and this is
another image I'm loading in a span with
just a little bit of padding to make
sure it appears like this and that's it
so we're going to do the same thing down
here to this section we have some some
white squiggly things and we're going to
put those in so let's uh let's go over
here where's our index page so home page
alright let me make this a little bigger
let me know if you can't see this text
it looks big to me but uh depending on
your screen it might be too small
yeah sorry I just take it a drink
drinking a lot of G fuel I don't know if
you guys ever heard of G fuel it's
basically like an energy drink powder
it's like has the same stuff as 5-hour
energy but it's cheaper and you get it
like in a big tub of powder so that's
keeping me awake right now and I'm not
sponsored by G fuel so I didn't get paid
to say that
I actually use it and it works what am I
trying to do you can see I'm a little
bit I'm a little bit out of it I'm like
losing focus more easily than I usually
do all right I always have a mission at
the top I'm trying to copy and paste
this okay here we go so we're going to
copy and paste this line not everything
but we'll have this bit okay so it's
hard to see we'll check it out when we
copy it but I've grabbed the images and
we're going to go down here to this
section where it says formation I'm just
going to copy this out and then I'll
change the text back to formation this
section originally said something like
building the church and I changed it to
formation and I put that elsewhere but
then now that's gone at this one I'm
just going to leave it a formation
because I'm afraid building the church
is going to be too big for this section
and it's going to write the words are
going to wrap maybe we'll change it
we'll see I might get an email at some
point saying that we have to change it
all right so this let me save and let's
just see what happened okay awesome so
we have these in here we're not going to
use these images obviously we're going
to use we have some other squigglies so
I need to check I need to find my left
folder I'll throw in over here I need to
see where the other squigglies are
so not that one not that one all right
we need squiggly three reverse and
squiggly three oh that's great
I don't I don't even have to change the
names very much let's throw in let's
just whoops oh yeah here
squiggly too we use our multiple cursors
and put in three and it's safe oh nice
all right it's not too bad it looks like
this should be a little bit farther to
the right I just got a message from my
boss hold on let me check
okay I got some more text so we'll be
putting that in next don't let me forget
okay yeah that's not bad but that
definitely needs out that's like that's
really weird because I thought I had let
me check the values let's say we have a
margin right why is that margin right
that should be left let me check this
out that I messed this up with up I did
all right I can't believe I didn't catch
that before okay so basically what I did
is that this should be Morgan left when
I I did the first one and I copy and
pasted over and I forgot to switch it so
Morgan left and I did the same thing up
here Morgan left now let's save it and
that should that should fix it there we
go
so that popped out that popped down a
little bit I mean that's that's actually
fine I think let me make sure okay so I
do have okay that works you can see once
the screen gets so small that it would
be probably get cut off then I just hide
them completely
there we go all right that works so
let's see how long did that take us not
too long we're gonna this is a 1 so this
came in exactly as we scheduled it was
about I'm rounding it was a little bit
more than a half of a Pomodoro session
but really close all right now let's put
in this text and I do have I have
something in here just in general for
text add text there we go all right and
it was this text but then I added some a
bit all right let's see what we have let
me open up what I never watched just
sent me anything
all right so bring this over the text is
really small but just so you can see
like basically just send me some text
and he told me where to put it on the
page so I'm just going to copy and paste
that onto faith right now
this is going to be on the about page so
a lot of this text I have pulled from
the original site and so I've just been
waiting on it obviously these images are
going to change instead I've put them
down here and their own cards these
cards are a little bit different than
they were so I actually resize these
images and now they're all uniform and
have the right links in there let's see
I can barely read this text too small
even on my screen I have on on my other
screen the text we're going to copy and
paste so that's a second section now I
have several paragraphs it's always like
I mean does look nicer when you break
your text up but when I have to manually
put in the text I don't like when I have
to keep putting in paragraph tags I know
it's not that much work let me just get
rid of some of this stuff we've
cluttered up and we don't need most of
this now the news page is actually going
to be completely hidden at first because
we don't
we have very much news we just have like
a couple of headlines that are links to
places so that doesn't really it's not
enough content to warrant having an
entire like blog set up in general I my
rule from back when I used to do a lot
of search engine optimization work was
if you don't have at least 300 words put
on the page then it shouldn't be its own
page that was that seemed to work for me
before I'm not really up on everything
that's new with search engines but at
least you know a couple years ago that
was kind of the bare minimum you needed
to be taken seriously for page to be
taken seriously by Google's a crawler
about there it is
it's an alphabetical order I don't know
why it took me so long to find that
probably because I was trying to talk at
the same time all right so this is the
car where we're above that or above that
we're going to we're trying to go to the
second section you see that this is so
much more than I would ever normally put
in a react component these pages are
basically just components but eventually
all this will be cut down and just be
templated and pulled in through the
WordPress API but for now it's like it
actually reminds me when I first learned
how to do websites I was using notepad
at the time Windows notepad so this is a
little more colorful but you know just
all the code right there in front of you
all right I think this is the section
let me double check no it's not I think
I need to go up home yeah it's this one
okay
so is what we'll do some copy and
pasting and let's copy and paste that
let's make a couple more P tags we need
two more class name always remember to
use classname instead of class and
you're at components or else you'll
you'll either get eye
they're reacting freak out you can air
or it just won't consider that class at
all it will just act like it doesn't it
wasn't on there and your Styles won't
get applied let's do one I need one more
paragraph okay I really need to learn
Emmet at some point I don't know if
people ever use Emmet or heard about
Emmet but it's like allows you to just
write HTML just super quickly with all
these little shortcuts I've known about
it for years and I've seen videos and
always wanted to learn but I just never
took the time to do it
but in times like these it would
probably come in handy all right let me
just say that see how it looks before we
do the rest all right okay so we get
three paragraphs okay we definitely need
a new image this is just not working
here I mean obviously it's not even
aligned properly if I don't get a new
image before it's time to launch it this
section will just be full with text that
goes basically everywhere in the site
it's going to be like that at some point
I'm just going to say like we have to
launch because I'm going to fall asleep
while I'm working if we don't and I
still I need to be awake because once we
launch any point the domain I need to
quickly set up the SSL for the new
domain so I can't be totally wiped out
at that point I need to be able to
handle any issues that might come up so
anyway we will cut any images that just
don't look right it's better to just not
have them to have been to have an image
that that's just not big enough and
doesn't fit in that section at least
that's my view I'd always rather just
completely hide sections that aren't
complete and then users don't realize
that they're missing out on something
they don't even know it's supposed to be
there to begin with and then when you
finally do make the you know that new
section of the site or that new feature
available then it's like people are
getting something as a bonus instead of
feeling like all this is still under
construction so
yes that's my little takeaway if I mess
up the rest of the video I think that's
still good advice online hub for local
learning let's see is that title in
there no all right so we need to add a
title tag all right we'll make this and
I think I'm making these h2s let me
check in interior section so I just want
to make sure I'm consistent consistent
h2s here H for a my dawn then this is an
h2 we're going to try an h2 uh I kind of
think maybe I just went with an h4 here
because this was really big I don't know
what I was like I'm not going to change
that but I it's just weird to have
different sections basically it's the
same level in the page hierarchy but I
have different H tags so that's not a
good idea don't don't do that I'm only
going to leave that because I'm running
out of time so this will be an h2 in
this section uh let's see all right so
we want this to span the whole section
be centered over the whole thing so
we're going to make another row within
the container class name row and let's
just add Center wet Center in there I'm
not sure if we need that but I might as
well put it in now so say some time and
then I'm going to put this in I don't
think I need to put in a call and
occasionally I've had weird things
happen when I don't
with this in a column and the system it
this is the grid system that comes with
materialized so I've had weird things
where like the H tag will like spill out
over the row and cause issues like on a
small screen where there's a horizontal
scrolling happening and and the cause is
this H tag spilling out that if I put it
in a column and it's just a fool with
Collin then it fixes the problem so if
you ever had that issue in material ass
that might fix it there we go finally
we're gonna have the h2 and paste that
let's see if it looks good all right
that works it is a little big as an h2
let's shrink that down and just see like
mmm four lines that's not terrible
really don't like a header to span four
lines but if I if I had time at some
point probably I put a media query in
and shrink the size of these headers of
all the headers down on on a small
screens let's oh goodness
I got bullet points to put in and then
exit reshape this myself I know it's
small but look not only are there
paragraphs but then there's bullet
points goodness it's not a big deal if
you have like a WYSIWYG but we got to
make this you oh so now lies by hand the
old-fashioned way okay so this text is
changing yes yeah
okay cool so that's their this next one
we're going to have another paragraph
and we'll put the UL in that picture we
need two more paragraphs here one
paragraph is going to have a line and
then a ul we'll see how that looks
I don't know how to look right off the
bat there's my timer so let me actually
I'm gonna I'm going to do the five
minute break for my timer right now and
that will just give me time to to keep
track of everything so I'm not going to
take a break from the live stream but
I'm going to take a break so I can come
in here say that was only half upon I
call Pomodoro sessions palms for short I
don't know if anybody else does that if
it sounds silly but if you hear me say
that that's like what I call it to
myself I'm going to bring in I'll show
you what I'm doing over here
I know it's really small but just to get
an idea
I also track my time here so I'm going
to say I actually forgot the last two
sessions so I'm going to double up and
say it was about sixty so I'm like
manually putting in the time at some
point I'd like to automate a lot of this
and just have another time in and then I
just make a little note of what I've
been doing I did set of the hover today
menu so you put that in there what do we
do we added squigglies page headers and
what are we working on now new text yeah
new text for about page okay another
super small but I just read out what I
was typing so you know that so basically
this is how I keep track of things so
all the time I've been spending on this
deal now I don't track me
eating's so sometimes meetings do take
our big part of a project so I only
track the time that like I'm actually
coding or you know looking up I mean we
all know that coding is a lot of
googling as well so that's my time so so
far in this project I actually spent
like 48 and a half hours on this uh so
we'll see so that gives me an idea of
how much time I've taken I have it all
my projects that I'm working on or have
worked on or all different sheets down
here so it's nice that I can go down
sometimes I actually put like an hourly
rate down here and keep track of it so I
can get some point go to my boss and say
like hey this is how much this project
may have cost you if you went with you
know an outside contractor so it's kind
of cool because if you add up what I've
done in a year it's it's always way more
than I get paid in a year so that means
that I am I am bringing value I'm a good
investment for this university and it
also gives me leverage if I wanted to
ask for a raise or something at some
point so I recommend keeping track of
that thing even if you're not an hourly
worker I'm not hourly I'll take a paid
salary salary but it's good to keep
track of I got about two minutes before
my breaks over we're going to start up
again so I'm just going to check the
live chat there's a lot going on the
live set so I'm not going to scroll all
the way up it looks like did somebody
somebody volunteered to be moderator
said I volunteer as tribute
um oh I didn't I didn't see that earlier
let me check if if they're still
craziness going on in the chat then
though maybe look up how to make you a
moderator squeezes Java developer
somebody asked if react to jess is the
only framework that
I know um I worked with angular before
but not in a while like maybe out of
like four years ago or something I did
some stuff with Hank so it was angular
one I've read about other frameworks
like the newer versions of the angular
and view j/s and then in terms of like
non JavaScript frameworks I have had to
work with things like C char PHP stuff
but yeah for now i'm just i'm working
with react at this point reactive is
more than enough for me to try to have
to learn so I'm not going to move on to
anything else right now but I'm
definitely interested I like to use the
right tool for the job so I'm interested
in learning some other stuff I just keep
seeing so many headlines about how great
few jss so I just I don't know I haven't
used it yet to my ass about CSS library
all right they got an answer
materialized y'all are great you you uh
you answer these questions right here
hey somebody says they like G fuel to
somebody but we believed in you when
they used emoji so it's actually B and a
leaf I love that that's so cool there's
a lot of message retracted sin here I
don't understand that why why is
somebody keep retracting the messages
and how does that I don't know I've
never really participated in live chats
myself so I'm not sure how you retract
the message
yeah materialized is open source it's on
github materialized is not material
design it's different material design is
like the basic like design philosophy
developed by Google and materialises is
like an incarnation of that design
philosophy so actually putting those
ideas into HTML CSS and JavaScript there
are other material design style
frameworks out there but I tried a bunch
of them um probably a couple years ago
and at that time react or materialized
was the one that was the most it was had
the least amount of bugs it was easier
for me to use so I don't know at this
point if there's something better but it
still maintains there's the shriek one
update so I'm still going with it
somebody said okay so so just to comment
so I mentioned real quick before we
start again somebody says I don't know
how you look I think I have a picture on
my my youtube channel so there's a link
in the description for the for this
video to my youtube channel and my
twitter I think and there are pictures
of me on on both of this so I don't know
I've never had a reason to actually show
my face on a live stream so maybe one
day I will but for now I don't somebody
else said they retracted their statement
because they were there talking about
the a versus e and the word effect and I
it turns out I was correct so awesome I
had a 50-50 shot at being right you know
it's only can only go one of two ways
alright so let me get back into this I
didn't get through everything that was
in the live chat there's a lot going on
so on the next break I'll I'll do the
same thing and I'll check back in I do
want to see okay we still have 33
viewers that's a little bit lower than
we normally have but that's that's a
decent mount of people so I'll keep
going in case you missed at the
beginning I'm just going to keep the
stream going for a while but maybe even
till I launched the site unless I I
might have to take a break to go out and
like meet with my boss or so that that
may happen so may not be straight
through but I think this is doable
let me get is I'm still waiting on some
content and some images anyway so I
can't I can't actually launch right now
so we're just going to try to get as
many like little things done as we can
all right so we will right in the middle
of making a paragraph tag with the class
name
of flow text flow text comes built-in to
materialize and it just makes your font
size change depending on the screen
width so it's like a responsive font so
I like it it's very helpful and it saves
me from having to test fonts sizes on
different screens and what I think I
need one more so let's copy this and
let's bring this in so we are going to
paste this and then I'm going to try to
put the UL right here I'm not exactly
sure how this is going to work out with
the padding if it's going to be up too
close but I just don't remember what the
default padding is materialise for this
we got some allies how many do we need
one two three four four a large so let's
copy that now we can copy some of this
over by default materialise does not put
any little dots or anything by there
they're allies so we'll see how it looks
if it's not obvious that this is a list
we may have to put in some of our own
hopefully it is obvious and it works now
you'll see what I'm talking about in a
second when we save this and one more
one more Li
and hopefully since we put that in the
paragraph tag that had flow text are ul
will also use the flow text that was
part of the idea of putting it in there
oh it's terrible there we go all right
let's flip over ah shoot all right this
is are you oh that looks awful what is
going on here see this it like you you
think like all I have to do is copy and
paste some text content but it's never
that simple well alright well I I don't
mind like this this padding here is fine
I like that
there there needs to be at least like
some indentation or something I guess I
could just change this and see what it
looks like now I'm gonna do like disk uh
I don't like using the disk how lucky do
you put them in up here um then we need
some some margins in here shoot 16
pixels all right see how this looks
that's not bad we'll keep we use that so
let's copy this and we will add it let's
see if I already have some I don't know
if I'm using
JSX in here yes I am where is the set
it's just in that section I'm going to
try to put it in here and see if it gets
scoped just to that section we may have
to move this I haven't used this style
JSX tag often enough to know exactly
what's going on with the scoping and I
just skimmed the the materials for the
the documentation only read like the
tiny bits that I really needed at the
time let's see where we're at
alright let me just give us a name um a
class name maybe we'll need it again so
- we'll just do it make it a class what
should we call this bullets let's call
it bullets not like gun bullets I don't
want to
how about circles or disks disk lists
okay cool what am i doing
yes there we go no there
I think it might be time for more G fuel
so I'm gonna feel really tired out of it
I also have Visine drops like for my
eyes and so when you're coding for a
long time your eyes start to dry out
those really help so may need to stop
and put some of those in as well I'll
just copy this paste it I mean okay and
see if it works I think it did what what
the heck just happened
oh my goodness what how how did that did
you guys just catch that what just
happened there
oh okay so a couple things are happening
that's first of all the styles are not
being applied here at all so I do need
to move that tag that style tag out
further so it's it's scoped to a bigger
scope and then also for some reason the
flow text tag is not being applied so
I'll do two things let's do two things
to try to fix this Vlad flow text to
here hopefully that works I really don't
want to have to add flow text to each
one of these allies but if this doesn't
work I'll have to and it's probably just
some that lifestyle overriding that I'm
assuming and now we need to take this
this whole thing here and move it
because it was just being scoped to the
shoot that I grabbed too I want to
double check yeah I just want to double
check and make sure I didn't grab the
div at the end of that and mess
everything up so let me move this all
the way out to like pretty much the
largest scope we have on this page I
could go out like one more but this
should work
hi no one ever found out live with idat7
wait a second I got that error a long
time ago and I fixed it
at least I thought I fixed it what the
heck was that all right now we got to
restart the dev server
okay assuming that that these changes
work that should be it for the for that
Li all right a little bit better not
exactly what we wanted at least we got
this flow Tech's working now this list I
still just looked in here to begin with
alright super simple fix they just have
a lot more like selectors here in the
CSS so I'm getting overridden
so we'll just throw in a couple more
selectors and we'll just override that
does it ever feel like a fight when
you're trying to override other CSS like
sometimes it does to me
alright so let's go with div UO when in
doubt just throw a div in there there's
probably always an enclosing giver on
something and I okay all right here we
go
unable to find an element with ID 87
what element is supposed to have idat7
what element is this so here's what I'm
going to do a refresh the page and hope
it works now I'm going to search for the
word ace the letters 87 87 oh man so
many 8730 187
you
maybe we can put that on the nb7
what the heck
maybe yes all right I narrowed it down
this list flow text 87 why is this
supposed to be
all right I'm going to check the live
chat real quick and see if anybody
caught caught anything
what is the stray oh did I did I mess
something up maybe I messed up a mess of
someone I copy and pasted all right let
me get me go up and check I mean that's
usually it when stuff like this happens
it's just you you misplaced it's
misplaced like semicolon or something
all right this looks this looks all
right I mean the highlighting helps to
anything that's you know inside of
clothes we'll get a different color that
looks all right let's check that style
tag here God that looks like it's
supposed to look in the move good all
right yeah somebody somebody had they
just retracted us in so I'm assuming
that they figured it out I'm just going
to say it
somebody's programming is so boring
sometimes it is sometimes it can be
tedious you just got to listen to some
music and just grind through it other
times it's fun I don't really know what
watching me do it might be pretty boring
but let's see yeah so when you do this
style JSX tag first you're going to put
brackets and that's going to basically
you're in react component so that that's
put you in JavaScript mode now then on
the JavaScript mode I use this this
little back tick and that's the
temporary template literal syntax so
think of this as using a single quote or
double quote except it can do cool stuff
so all this in here is basically a
string so I can write all the CSS just
like
normal CSS it since it's a string and
then it all gets changed over and
applied where it needs to get applied
for that component so when it comes out
on the other end it's it works
well in this case it's not working but
usually it works so let's go back and
we'll look at this again and see what's
going on
am I still I'm still getting so how's it
not even showing up at all I need to
make this bigger so we can see what's
going on okay so this Li should be
getting some styles that we put in and I
don't see it anywhere so our styles are
not even being applied at all let's
check to see if these styles are being
applied because these did work yeah
these styles are being applied let's
let's check this out
I'm just trying to rule things out here
okay so we can see this is what we
should be seeing as the styles getting
applied something like this this data
- JSX all right let's check that out
let's make sure we did it - you will
disclose uh I'm pretty sure I know what
I just did I added the class disc list
to the UL so I I shouldn't have had to
space that let's see if this works I
still might not be and it gave me that
same error we're definitely going to
have to test this out on the live server
because if we're getting this error on
the live server that's a huge problem I
think it's it's only happening when I
hit save and the hot module reloading
happens so I'm I think it's only with
the hot module reloading and that's fine
because then it won't mess up anything
in production but once remember to test
that
okay still not happening but let's see
alright at least it's here so we just
need to add one more we need to make it
more specific so I hate making things so
specific but let's go with main and then
and that's that's good and kind of
annoyed no how is that not this is this
is really terrible it's like alright now
I just I just have to do this I have to
go
just like the nuclear option I should
have just done this five minutes ago
then that's the thing I can't remember
how I fixed that same issue last week oh
man
wait a second you guys might have
already seen this I haven't looked at a
live shot in a couple minutes I'm an
idiot
if you didn't catch that
haha they did alright somebody did
somebody already caught that three
minutes before I did I should have just
I should have just checked the live chat
sorry oh man I applied it to those
triangle flights in the UL instead of
the Li that was the problem
alright well that is finished I'm not
going to mess with that I'm like I just
don't want to deal with that anymore so
it's gonna look like that alright let's
see alright one more for this page let's
do all right we're actually we're going
to use blockquote for this one so if you
haven't use blockquote yet you will
you'll see it up alright so we got this
section here let's go up or the last one
alright so here's a section we just
today we're going to drop down one
section and we're going to add a block
quote
crunch then I'm gonna add flow text
again oops okay now I'm going to bring
in this text and they say it was a given
I put that in the right spot right
thought I did I am starting to lose my
voice a bit sorry about that did a
circuit again with this the dev server
that's why me okay
somebody's at such tab I think that
that's right about the time when I was
typing important phone there I probably
don't need it now I can take it out but
I I'm not gonna go back and take it out
right now alright this should be good
enough and then let's see alright
awesome so we've got this little plot
quote right here and I want to make this
match the home page because we have a
quote on the home page - let's make it
Madison's check out the home page and
see how we did it alright so we don't
have any parentheses and it looks like
we're making the name of the document
italicize let's see what this is okay so
we need to change up how this is format
it a bit and I don't know should we go
with the black I think we should we
should make this black background yeah
you don't have in here and then we'll
make this red okay so let's do the
shortcut mode on this and just copy and
paste some stuff we're going to copy
this border and let's throw it on here
and I'm just going to put it in here and
if I haven't already showed you this and
so show you got to do it if you're using
next jazz I don't know if this works
with just regular reacts but on on next
jazz they have this CSS and J's thing I
think that's what it's called and you
can just type in it's basically like an
object it's not like not a it is an
object so javascript object so these
first set of brackets says hey we're
going to do some JavaScript now so
anything inside those brackets is
JavaScript and then the second set of
brackets is an object and so you just
type in all right no no no hyphens here
you can okay shared CSS stuff and then
you put this stuff in quotation marks
let's see if that works it should work
we're getting that again okay we it did
we're Bowie you can barely see it
because we didn't make the background
black I listen to the inspector and it
is it's really already use dev tools
when it's blown up so big what I do want
you want to be able to see so red
background flourish let's just remove
that class and add a black background
okay simple case we're going to move
this class which gives it the red
background and that little squiggly
thing in the background here and we're
going to keep white text we're going to
keep I'm not I don't even remember what
the class banner is going but we're
going to keep it and we were not going
to add another class I'm just going to
throw background right directly on here
with the style tag if this is just like
making you cringe this is not exactly
like frowned upon in reacts throwing
your CSS in the middle when I first
started doing this it's like so freaked
out because you guys I've always been
like been taught I didn't really go to
school for this but I've always read and
seen everybody say no you got to
separate out your CSS and the separate
files don't put inline CSS but then with
react it's okay
so it takes some getting used to my
Pomodoro cycle just ended let's just
throw this in since we're so close to
having it ready um background
color red I'm playing Spotify and on my
headphones in the background and have
this 90s rock playlist and I'm not like
super into rock I'm actually I listen to
whatever I'm not picky but it like
brings back so many memories of hearing
these songs when I was younger so it's
kind of cool they had a pretty good
throwbackthursday playlist there was a
lot of like 90 stuff that was nostalgic
for me so if you have Spotify what did I
just do why did I say red I'm losing it
guys guys and girls sorry
you I'm losing it people I don't know
there's nothing and I don't why would I
put their name I never do that okay
alright let's try that again I need to
get off this page alright awesome so we
have that done the only thing we need to
do is just clean this section up here to
make it look like the the quote on the
home page so let's go back over what do
we do
I'm actually I want to look at the the
index page while we're here because I
think I made okay I did it I did it in
line I just did a spam okay
I think the tearless actually has a
class for italic I don't think it's I
don't think it's worth it time wise for
me to look up that class right now
because it would take me longer than to
just copy and paste this but I'm pretty
sure that it is a class alright so they
use caritas best anybody anybody good
with Latin you want to tell me what that
means I'll tell you what it means in a
minute but I'll give you guys a minute
to see if anybody knows Latin I used to
teach Latin in high school I haven't
worked with in so long I'm really rusty
but
um I still remember some of it ah spam
and no Google Translate no cheating if
you really know what this is a lobby
then then put it in the in the live chat
okay that's what we need and there we go
there's the other one and that's that
should be it should be right do we need
we need to comment it up with the
comment the in a coma okay and that that
really should be it
alright perfect so that's matched up
exactly with one on the homepage this
picture is not going to stay I don't
know what we're going to put here yet
I wanted I'm going to see how it looks
real quick with no picture I actually
will probably just leave it in that in
those columns so I think I kind of like
it off to the side like that happen
let's say well that's that's happening
more frequently that's not good
alright let me go back over all right
somebody did get so John John Heiner got
it they got the they got the answer so
hopefully in google Sharon's like that
but yeah in Latin they translated a
caddy toss past Ghana so today uses God
Caritas is actually like so that's where
we get the word charity from but in
theological terms charity and love are
like the same theological like thing
that the same virtue so so they're in
Latin it's pretty interchangeable
today's concept of love is usually
different than the meaning we give to
charity but if you're reading like some
old-school theology stuff maybe in Latin
then you can use those words
interchangeably pretty much so little
Latin lesson for today and then s this
just is so in Latin word order doesn't
mean anything so all right John Ida says
they legitimately translated that no
Google Translate so awesome if I had
like a gold star I would give it to you
that's really cool
not too many people
we'll know any Latin nowadays I mean
it's pretty much no one speaks it
conversationally people just read it
actually I don't mind that off to the
side let me know what when you all think
having this off to the side I definitely
just need some padding
I don't like calculus that is but right
off to the side that's not bad
sorry my voice is going yeah often the
side is pretty good man I forgot to
start my poem into our timer again so
let's uh that's all the text content
that we needed to put in for that
section so let's just give this the next
show so this is three right we went a
little over I mean really it's like
three point five I can't leave it took
that long to do text I'm just going to
throw this over here because I think we
have all the text we need now I don't I
don't think I'm waiting on anything else
hopefully actually I wrote out a list
earlier sometimes it doesn't focus if I
actually write it on a piece of paper
with a pen so okay you need a text for
the about and yeah I think that's the
only place I needed text for so great so
we're done with that
let me I'm gonna put in the time over in
my other spreadsheet as well and stupid
timer all right 3:30
I may have to take a break and eat
something at some point I just realized
I have eaten nothing today I'm not
feeling well I had like a like a protein
like weight gain type of shake this
morning so I haven't like eaten anything
that was like you have to chew but I did
drink that so I'm not like I'm not
running on no calories at all but very
very few calories at this point I do do
you ever do that when you get working
you just
forget to eat I do that frequently all
right so at this point let me I want to
make sure I didn't get any more messages
what are the dimensions for the headers
uh I did get a message um so you asked
me what dimensions I needed for the
title for that like the header images so
the thing that I'm calling the title
here these images the images that I have
are not quite as big as I want to see
you see if someone has a big screen I
think this is 27 inches and this is this
is like the Apple like they're a doll
monitor which is called like a
thunderbolt I forget what it's called so
it's like a 2k screen I think so you can
see I don't know if you can see this it
looks like it's pixelated somebody here
should this is somebody that I work with
and he said look like a watercolor
painting so this image it actually kind
of works if you want to pretend it's a
watercolor painting but I need bigger
images so my boss just asked me what
dimensions and I think mm width will
probably work I should double-check that
and make sure that this image isn't
already mm and I'm going to go here and
just see no it's not these are 1,200
these width of 1200 so that's that's no
good
unless you're going to limit the width
of your page to 1200 you need something
bigger than that because screens are
just like crazy these days with size and
resolution you can't get away with 1200
with anymore at least that's what I
think I work on a 27-inch 5k screen and
then my secondary monitor is 20 I think
27 maybe 25 I don't know a a 2k screen
so I probably have better screens than
most people do but still you know you
want to develop for what's coming you
know
try to be as cutting edge as you can so
you don't have to redo it in a few
months
all right let's let's get rid of the
space and move on we'll save I did want
to just add some pie before we start the
next item on the list let's just add
some padding real quick I'm actually
just I think I'm just going to add grab
this section and just add margin to the
bottom this will be easy uh normally I
don't like to do this little like piece
by piece thing but you know we're just
so close to being finished I just want
to get it done and I'm super tired and
hungry right now
I wish we don't have like good food
delivery where I'm at so I some like
bigger cities now you can just like have
food delivered from a restaurant like
right from your app you just pick it I
really really want that here but I live
in a town that what's a city technically
but there's only like I don't know
16,000 people something like that so I
guess it's not nobody's making money
doing that here so you can pretty much
only get pizza delivered maybe what I
want here
let's go 50 see how that looks all right
I like that 50 works let's go here and
we'll just add this right ends we
already have that tag there
margin-bottom 50 pixels
well east of 31 viewers so that's
impressive
for those of you have stuck with it for
most of the time I've been on some
people maybe you're new and you have
them in here the whole time if you're
just getting here I'm working as fast as
I can
uh and fighting exhaustion and a cold to
launch this site today and they're
allowing these tiny changes oops I got a
call before you some changes let me take
this hello hey
yeah let me let me see yeah I just
haven't checked my email so maybe this
extreme is why it was originally
expected pattern has occurred okay
all right so let me let me know exactly
it doesn't sorry in Google Chrome your
uh what machine is ISM window
it's a Mac one up wood version operating
system you do you know okay maybe it's a
no captive
um so there's there's two things that I
can think of that it could be at this
point maybe number one it's possible
that some something is cached that is
not it's just messing something up with
the site as it is now in which case you
have to do like a like a hard reset or
you could try to go into one of those
browsers in my private browsing mode and
look at the site that'll tell you if
it's the cache or not the second thing
that it could be is that it's possible
that both Safari and maybe even Chrome
the latest versions of them have not
come out for El Capitan that's that's a
long shot Safari for sure
they cut off the versions but I just
can't see chrome doing that yeah so it
worked on the same machine yesterday
all right then it has to be I would I
would guess that it's something with the
caching so I would try it in a in a
private browsing window and you can call
me back let me know if that doesn't work
I'm just as I can't troubleshoot it
because I can't get it everything I try
to view it on I can see it so I keep
trying I keep trying maybe I'll ask some
other people hmm
yeah and I should it should be an option
to do private private yeah shoot I'll
have some other people over here
oh yeah I'm sure we probably have
computers open because we're not you
know we don't have as many swap workers
as normal right now so that'll or two
yeah yeah okay yeah no yeah um
yeah I think it could be I think it
could be live I mean they're not not
like every single feature is going you
know necessarily needs to be like like
we we don't need like a really robust
search mechanism right now because you
can look through every resource in 30
seconds so so things like that but you
know for the things that you know are
important the main portions of the site
you know they I'm going through right
now I'm looking at like padding and
things just kind of tweaking a little
bit so so they will be ready to go but
yeah if you want to come on over and
check that out I do I think I'm gonna
have some other people to check it out
on their machines though too because I
want to know what's going on with that
mm-hmm
okay
oh yeah gives the linkage
okay okay all right so that'll be yes
we'll take out the the button there the
link button for now and put something
like okay
that's that's true I just don't have
that PDF or is it already up somewhere
okay send it send it to Tom and and then
I'll have him upload it somewhere that I
can link to it okay all right thank you
hi Ron
okay I am back
that was the Vice peseta assistant
director of the department that I'm
making the site for so come in a big
problem he's running uh he's on a Mac
he's running El Capitan and on both his
version of Chrome and Safari which which
are up-to-date he's getting an error
when he tries to go to the test site so
the site so if you all could try to go
to the test site if you can the links in
the description
it's just test katic addicts calm I
don't expect anybody to know how to
spell cat akattak so I always have to
think hard about it too so use the the
link so if you're just joining you're
wondering why I was just on the phone
with someone this is this is just my
normal work day
alright I'm I'm narrating my work day
but at times I get a rough interrupted
so I got you know I have to talk to I am
getting paid to do this work so I can't
ignore everyone else so I see we did
lose some some viewers if the viewer
account gets down really low then I'll
probably just cut off the stream because
it's obviously nobody wants to see it at
that point but otherwise I'll keep it
going for a while I think it would be
cool to keep it going until I launch but
I suspect that might not
happen for two reasons one uh I think
some other people will have to look at
the site before I get the go-ahead to
say like it's going to go live and I
don't want to just wait here and have
nothing going on to wait on their their
response and there go ahead the other
reason is I'm I'm getting just like
super hungry right now so I'm gonna have
to take a break so if possible it's
possible that maybe I can just live
stream later on I don't want to take up
the free code camp channel like all day
so if I have to stop and then livestream
later maybe I'll just do it on my
channel I just
I won't schedule it as an event I'll
just go on go on my channel we'll see
I'm gonna check the live chat really
quick see if if anybody got the same
error
somebody says Robert bled saw said I saw
the monstrous on the thumbnails like
what's going on here yeah you don't so
in case you don't know this is this is
up here this is a monstrance so it's a
Catholic thing
so I imagine that that would be kind of
odd to see that as like a coding video
come up but that's that's like the hero
image for the site and that's that was
like we had to have that image in there
everybody wanted that image to be in
there and prominence so yeah so that's
in there uh somebody's I think what's
the error of John's asking what's the
error um I don't know exactly what the
error message is I didn't get like a
copy and paste oh yeah actually let me
check my email and unexpected error has
occurred that's it I think it's just a
gray screen with unexpected errors
occurred I guess I just I keep trying to
go to all the pages there and I can't
get it to happen
someone says press one to die instantly
one not sure what's going on there
okay my boss just said he's having a
tough time finding the full versions of
those images the the larger versions to
work so we'll see how it goes I mean if
if we have to go with with these images
I mean the majority of people viewing
the site probably will have a screen
small enough that it would work but I
don't really want to take that bad
gamble I think it's just the site a site
just looks a lot worse when you have
images that aren't the proper size and
they're they're pixelated so I really
rather not have to do that so he's the
kind of thing I don't know if I can keep
streaming the whole time because some of
these things are a little bit out of my
control and it's been a children
creators good son okay so John says
tried it then it looks fine shoot yeah
and it's not entirely it's not entirely
updated I haven't pushed the changes to
the server in a while so it won't match
up with what you're saying here on my
local version exactly but all right well
I can see your scroll bars in the team
cards okay you can see you can see
scroll bars what browser are you on that
you can see the scroll bars because I
definitely want to get rid of those
let's do that next on the lid that's on
my list so I knew it happened in IE 11
um oh actually I have a great idea let's
go to browser stack I don't know I
didn't think this browser stack and
[Music]
let's go to Mac El Capitan and we'll try
out let's just let's try out Safari and
we'll see uh because this is what the
other guy was running when he got the
error I'm assuming he was running the
most updated one so if we try to go on
here maybe we can get the same error
if you've never used all right we got it
let's check it out what's the problem
here
anybody want to take a guess I'm pretty
sure I know what the problem is but
we'll see
take a guess before we check out dev
tools inspect element all right so we're
going to see let's see we got three
errors I'll give you a second another
second to say what the error is before I
click over I'll tell you I think it's
because I'm using es6 stuff and maybe
this version of Safari can't handle the
es6 stuff in it maybe yesterday the day
before we did switch other yesterday we
switched out and transpiled some of the
code so it would work but then I
switched back to the other code because
I wasn't finished editing it yet so
let's see can't kind of chimera yes
that's it that is the error okay so
that's great that is great news the
error is simply that I'm using the
variable let well instead of air I'm
using let that's a es6 thing that is not
supported in this version of Safari it's
weird that it was happening on chrome 2
but maybe maybe chrome was older I don't
know but that's it so basically what
will happen is we'll double check we'll
come back to this and double check once
we transpile the javascript it might be
worthwhile to just transpile the
JavaScript right now and put it on there
I don't foresee let's say let's see if
let's just check out our list and see if
we have anything that's going to be jobs
you're teddy
no I don't I don't think there's
anything left we need to do we want to
edit that javascript file lets transpile
it we'll put it on the server and then
we can test it immediately and make sure
that that was in fact the problem if you
want to know more about the whole issue
with the Essex and let watch yesterday's
show because I explained it in more
depth yesterday uh where am I going
I just I want to say just forgot where I
was trying to go Oh
babble try it out ok I don't know if I
actually I could try to use this one but
in the off chance that I did edit this
since yesterday I don't know if I did or
not we'll just get rid of all this and
we'll go in normally I would set up like
automatic transpiling but I didn't do
that yet so I'm just going to do this I
only really have one file that needs
transfer so big we're good to go with
that let me can I do cooking it this
oh well forget go get it cool so we got
this transpiled
we'll throw it in over here I'm not even
going to worry about backing this up
because I have this Said's from like so
many previous commits I could just grab
it from from github so let's say that we
got a wish my console here it is let's
check out figure out what we've been to
one what was the last thing we changed
did add content yeah wonder less commits
that hover effects okay so what we did
we added
it's good ways we did add some
squigglies and we updated about text and
transpile no no we never put past as we
update about it and transpile this
alright that's good alright awesome now
let's let's go to the server so I got
server over here actually this might be
too small for you want to see let me let
me bring it up a little bit there we go
maybe that's better
so just just like we've been doing the
last couple days ssh into the server and
this time i got everything ready so I'm
just chaining these commands with this
double and sign I don't think this works
on Windows I think it just works on
Linux based stuff so be careful using it
with Windows I'm not sure but um I think
that's the way it works so this will
just do all the stuff that we were doing
manually before so it stopped it went
into the directory a man did it miss
something there's no way it was that
fast no yep I was I mess up one thing so
in fact it did not work because I messed
that up I needed to add run sunny npm
run build efficiency right here I left
that out that's important so let's just
run it again they will see you
oh my goodness let me just use this
portion actually now this will work if I
just CD out because this is assuming
that I just loved him okay that was
supposed to save me time you see it did
not it will later on now that it it's
actually the right command I'll just be
able to throw that right in I know
there's probably a way for me to just
like have this saved on the server and
call it out but I'll set that up at some
point actually here's a good question
for for everybody do you know of a way I
know this is possible but I just haven't
done it before where I can set this up
so that I'll have zero downtime when I
update so like right now there's brief
downtime while this thing builds
somebody showed me the site right now
nothing would you know they'd seen hair
what I want to happen is like maybe two
different versions of this basically a
duplication of this this node you know
at running and like so I can take one
down but then nginx will automatically
redirect traffic to the other one update
one then bring that one back online and
then update the other one is there a way
to do that if you know they'll be
awesome if you can give me like a link
or something
I probably won't have time to do it
right now but that would that would be
great to implement in this project and
some future projects as well alright so
that should be online now let's I'll
check it out real quick right here yeah
okay that works now the real test let's
go back in here it loves you up pretty
quick and browserstack if you don't do
anything no sense in wasting a lot of a
lot of bandwidth and because they I mean
these are like real like virtual
machines and stuff you're on our own
machines so alright yay it works now all
right let's click around just to be sure
see so that was it that was the problem
I was using some newer features of
JavaScript that we call es2015 features
or sometimes you hear es6
I was using some of those features that
are not supported in Safari 9.1 so
that's why I didn't work uh I also let's
see what browsers they have I wonder if
they have another browser no they don't
I don't know
let's stop this and go out I guess each
instance you have to like I was hoping I
could just stay in that one instance and
switch to Chrome but I can't so let's
try the latest one I was assuming that
install extension now I don't really
want to do that right now uh I was
assuming it was the latest version it
didn't work that's what they said
it said they're running the latest
version it's all up to date so we're
going to try it on there we'll make sure
that this works well that was that was
like a weird effect at first on if you
guys caught that but anyway alright it
is working work you're working good
great so yeah so if you're just joining
us we're getting errors because we were
using new JavaScript features so we
transpiled the code using babel and now
it works awesome so let's stop this we
don't need it anymore probably test a
little bit later on the launch if I have
any any strength left now let's get to
these scroll bars so I had some of you
say well he picked up a couple of years
I'm into a little while ago that I
forget to eat when I work and someone
said I forget to work when I eat I would
like to have that program a little bit
more often somebody else what are we
doing today we're in the site ready to
launch so we're doing anything that we
have to do to get it ready to launch so
a little bit of everything here testing
and troubleshooting just some browser
testing doing a lot of like tiny
like UI tweaks or even copy and pasting
some content in at some point hopefully
we'll get the domain name switched over
and we will set up the SSL but I might
have to take a break before that so
alright so let's get these somebody
yesterday I asked yesterday for some
code to hide the scroll bars so let me
let me put that in and I'm gonna check
the chat from yesterday and I saved it
there's some good information in there
there we go
uh okay weitzman now that's not it
scroll bar
okay so I'm going to copy some of this
let me scroll up to see what browser
okay they say they can see the browser
in the latest chrome version on Windows
10 shoot yeah
all right this thinks we're gonna have
to fix this so basically what happened
was I wanted all these cards to be the
same height so let's look at this
let's check this up now let's do accent
the team one is better I wanted all
these cards to be the same let me go on
the last side no good so I wanted these
to all be the same height but some
people have really long titles and they
were rapping on the other line
so as a quick fix I just added this
little scroll on a Mac you don't see it
so it still looks okay on Windows that
doesn't happen so here's what we're
going to do I'm going to open up Chrome
on Windows in browser stack so we'll
just go windows which are Windows 10 and
the latest version of Chrome I'm using
this so I can basically because I want
to be able to use the F tools Chrome's
dev tools as I like those the best then
I'm going to put in some of the code
from dev tools to see if it works
before we put it into a project it
loaded so of course we're good oh
goodness to scrollbars ah you're right
this does look really really bad I might
just have to truncate things or
I'm gonna set a limit on the titles okay
so maybe what am I going to put this on
not the card on the content let's move
this over a bit have some more space
areas where we have our old stuff okay
I'll shoot I can't can I'm not pace them
in here yes it worked all right so
there's some of it this isn't I've
gotten I bet some other stuff I'm going
to paste in and try to get it to work
oh um I should not a face about it
should because of this see it says
Nathan now because this would only work
for yesterday we're talking about
Internet Explorer's we need to see if
there's some equivalent
I know this isn't going to work but I
was worth a try okay so like a WebKit
version sure
yeah
all right so here's his thing we set
overflowed to none and we get rid of
these but then it's cut off
we need the yeah you're right so make
sure the scroll bars look or they do
look really bad all right here's the fix
right now at this point titles being cut
off is less of an issue than then these
scroll bars these look terrible because
we still have a modal that will pop up
and we can see the full title in the
modal so I'm going to let the titles get
cut off for now maybe go in and either
truncate the titles or possibly leave
out the title I hate to leave out the
titles I also don't think I really have
time to go in and manually like cut down
the titles so yeah you're right truncate
and you all were saying that yesterday
too I should have just tried to have the
truncate yesterday yeah this always felt
like not a great idea just kind of like
a quick solution and it was definitely
not a great idea so glad uh that I'm
really glad that you all caught that
thank you and this is what it I am a
little bit slower when I do the live
stream because I'm explaining things and
talking but you all catch stuff like
that so sometimes it really saves me a
lot of time or saves me from like
launching a site with a really ugly UI
in that case so I think it's a good
trade-off all in all you know we kind of
work on this collaboratively I give up a
little bit of my time but then I get all
of your collective knowledge to help as
well I think it's a good trade where did
I put this so we're done I'm closing out
app just because we transpired it we put
it on there I don't want to edit it
anymore
any more JavaScript that I have to write
I'm going to try to write directly in
the components if i use es6 and the
components it will get automatically
transcribed by next or
whatever they'll do something with it so
that it works behind the scenes so what
I want to do now is go let's go to that
team card component because I probably
put these in line styles on it overflow
what did I say none I think that's what
I did yep okay so this will do basically
we've prevented the text from wrapping
which is what we want so the cards will
be even otherwise you get like a really
weird stack if I had more time I would
try to use maybe something that would
possibly do like a masonry style layout
that could work I don't know but I don't
have time to mess with that in my
experience there's I've always taken
away like more time than I want them to
think when I try to do masonry layouts
with some type of JavaScript plug-in so
they're not going to make the cards all
different heights but it is going to cut
off this at the end here and I will it's
not going to be cut off on every screen
size certainly once the screen is bigger
it'll be off define once you're on a
phone and there's definitely going to be
stuff that gets cut off but all it takes
is one click to see it all I'm not
really happy about shipping the site
with that but I'd say that can go on the
list of things that don't absolutely
have to be ready today you can feel free
to disagree let me know why if you think
that that really should be fixed beside
the point now I gotta make some tough
decisions about what launches also I
don't really expect to get like a
million people viewing this site today
either so if we want and it's not like
perfect what's ever perfect when you
launch though but let's say it's not
perfect it's not like you know so many
people are going to see this I think the
last time this site is going to get more
viewers than
then my last time I had a really rush
project but last time had a really rush
project it was like super rush like can
you do this by tomorrow and I did it and
then for like two hours I looked at the
analytics and no one visited the site
and I was like are you serious
I stayed up half the night and then
slept for three hours and came in I
really did this site and no one even
went to it so that that was fed and I
was a super mad about it but it was
slightly annoying alright so we fix this
I forgot to set my timer again so I
guess I'll just estimate one the testing
of it took a little while it probably is
more like a half but it was close enough
all right the list is getting down it's
going down farther so let me check my
email real quick make sure we didn't get
any other changes yet oh it's like
alright I may have there's some new
content but I think it's stuff that can
be put in through the content management
system so I'm good with that
so I'm checking my email on the other
screen I don't don't think that the
people I work for would appreciate me
checking the email in front of everybody
watching on YouTube so I try to do
everything I can on the main screen but
there's some stuff that I shouldn't show
to the world not because it's bad it's
cuz it's just like you know private
stuff or a password or something like
that okay
alright we may have to make a change we
may have to change the link here in a
second that's not a big deal
all right sorry I'm reading an arene
email for my boss or at least one that I
get cc'd on okay this could be a major
change so shoot see I don't like this
might be something that should just be
put off because I don't think it's that
big of a deal right now but I mean the
people would suggest changes whether
they be a client or other people
involved their change always does seem
like an important change at the time and
the grand scheme of things I don't think
this is that important but here's the
change that might happen what is not
great right on because I zoomed in and
what I don't like this you see this
highlighting how it looks like oh I'll
check it out later on I guess um so this
is supposed to this is fully data in
from WordPress so this is a custom post
type with all these custom fields I'm
pulling it in through the API so this is
why it's a bigger change than it seems
it's been requested by I don't even know
I just give the email but to add another
section here that will say whether or
not this and that requires registration
my boss is arguing that it doesn't it's
not necessary to have that in there and
I tend to agree we already have a lot of
stuff here what would have to happen is
I'd have to go back in and edit that the
custom fields for that custom post type
and then I'd have to edit the code that
I'm using on the react side to pull that
in and add another thing so rather not
do that but
maybe it'll happen hopefully not do you
see it's kind of cool that the role that
my boss often plays for me is awesome
and that I wasn't directly I didn't have
to directly respond to that email
I am cc'd on that email I could see
what's going on but he is taking care of
that for me so that saves me a lot of
time and I'll see the focus so it's
definitely cool
I mean think if you were maybe at a
smaller agency or something like it
would be like the role of a project
manager I mean he's basically like a
project manager for all the projects
that we that we have here he also has a
lot of social media stuff he's good with
that all right I'm going to check the
live chat just for a second because I I
need just a little little break here oh
shoot I just remembered I have scroll
bars on another page too and I bet a
scroll bar shows up here I can't do
anything about that though yeah I can't
why is this alright so this is this is
annoying that this is dropping down
lower um that's that's a kind of like
small enough I don't need to worry about
that now it is going to bother me though
there's another page where we had scroll
but all right resources that's where get
scroll bars dang it those are going to
show up how bad do these look with
scroll worth take it alright let's check
it out with scroll bars let's go back in
here
yeah once again I keep saying people say
truncate somebody said add the truncate
class last time I tried to use truncate
it um it like wouldn't work on a
multiple line thing I said look at the
keep up with the live chat more often
because a minute again somebody just
said check resources that's where the
scroll bars are and I'm over here trying
to think about what it was not the team
so they're still on that I didn't push
the updates yet resources it's like the
scroll is not very good at all on this
I'm hoping it's just because it's on a
virtual machine like through browser
stack and this isn't actually the
experience for four people
I told up I got my wife calling I'm
gonna take this hello hey how's it going
oh you can watch I'm still on on YouTube
live you're on the live stream right now
yeah I just decided to keep live
streaming it because I'm like I'm really
out of it so I need some help
oh no don't don't worry about maybe a
gnome for dinner you guys can just eat
and I need you I don't need anything yet
so I need to take a break here
I need something oh my god
breakfast sandwich in the freezer I know
I miss you guys too
hopefully this will be the last day this
would be the last day and then I'll I'll
get up I'll get out early a bunch of
days coming up make up for it alright
now I love you oh no oh shoot oh yeah
just send me a text and remind me to do
it and I'll pick it up on the way love
you too right okay sorry about the
interruption
umm fishing stuff a month or two into
China line of stuff this is let me see
okay
so many laughs SS and lightning me see
awesome I'm glad that this is serving
some some purpose the nearby event isn't
it yet the nearby event thing that's
going to have it I can't really do
anything about that the that the other
people involved in the project actually
wanted the scroll bar in there that's
why I added the stuff on the bottom the
little buttons that scroll horizontally
because they wanted the scroll bar in
there but it wouldn't show up on Mac so
I'm going to leave that in there whether
whether or not it looks good is a
different question but they want to make
sure people know that you can scroll
sideways horizontally on that these
things alright let's let's try to add
this truncate class and see now let's
not do the here alright we got a link to
put on
say let's just throw this link on here
right now so I don't have to make a note
remember it oh we got it Google
Analytics strip to put on - awesome well
throw in both of those things to throw
in the script and hopefully I can do is
anybody can you just throw in analytics
Script under a react component does that
work I got to look up let me look up a
site I did a couple months ago because I
know I put analytics Script in there and
it was a react site I'm looking it up
right on the other screen mmm maybe I
would have put it in the footer
component that seems like a good spot
but I would have put it yep I did okay
oh you have to dangerously set H inner
HTML to get it to work good thing I
looked it up
now I'll copy and paste this and just
change the thing is there any danger in
me having my analytics property code out
I don't really know I'll just do it on
the other screen so basically no there's
no danger that's publicly viewable from
dev tools so forget it I'm not going to
put on another screen what am I thinking
yeah any code that's client-side code
everybody can see it anyway so somebody
just joined are you trying to suppress
scrollbars
yes I am somebody said I should mute my
mic when talking to someone else just in
case that's a good idea I haven't been
doing it just because I don't know how
to do it I've never had to mute my mic
yet and so I'm using software that OBS I
think and just like the default mic that
comes with an iMac so I never really had
a unit before so I'll have to look oh so
far I don't think I've said anything
that shouldn't have been heard
maybe there's stuff that you guys didn't
want to hear but I don't think it's
anything that
shouldn't have been there all right so I
need to add in to the footer component
the analytics code I've been waiting and
my boss made the analytics property you
got me the code this is actually the
code I used on a previous site so I'm
going to go back and just grab that if
you've never used Google Analytics on
your site this isn't the only way to do
it but this is one way that's easy you
just put in this code this is just
standard code that they give you and I
it's the same code all the time except
you just change out this little number
here in this ID number and then and then
it it works when you track it so I put
it in I try to put it in a component
that I know it's going to be everywhere
and there will be a footer the same
footer everywhere so now it'll be all my
pages so that's done and that was
actually on our list so we can move one
over that was super fast wonderful it's
just feel satisfying to move things over
to the done list and see it grow all
right correct URLs let's add what were
you going to do we were going to add
this this link in let me let me open
this and grab the link okay so there's a
button on the site now that goes to a
site that's not ready yet on the courses
page so this is basically just like kind
of a marketing site for this program
this is a whole like custom learning
management system and this is supposed
to link to it but it's not ready there's
not even like a coming soon page yet so
we need to replace this with it's
actually just going to link to a PDF Oh
somebody said you can use obs with a
hotkey so cool yeah this says somebody
asked if the session will be available
after it ends it will be available I
have to watch though okay I'm
it I think like a session after like
four hours maybe it doesn't get there
was some limited four hours I remember
reading about so hopefully I won't take
four hours actually I am going to take a
break really soon maybe maybe as soon as
I update this link I'm going to do it
also try to do like I'll try to truncate
that what I'm just getting too hungry
and I can't even think right now so I'll
take a break and then maybe so here's
what I'm going to do I'm going to take a
break at right after I do this link then
I'm not going to do another livestream
on free code camp channel because
they're they're nice enough to let me
stream on this channel and I don't want
to take advantage of that and be on here
all the time and you know I don't know
if this content is going to be like
really good what they kind of what they
want so if I come back and stream later
on which I might do I'm gonna do it on
my own channel so you can go to my
channel there and see if there's a
stream happening I'm not trying to beg
for subscribers here but if you
subscribe I think you will get an alert
if I go live so if you want to get
alerted you know go ahead and do that
but I'll stream on my channel and then
that way I don't you know I can I can
stream and and be really tired like I am
and if I say something crazy or do some
crazy cuz I'm tired then I won't be an
embarrassment to free code camp at that
point it would just be to myself so so
that's the plan let's just change this
link I mean not not that you all want to
watch me change a link that's pretty
simple uh-huh little phases that on
courses I'm glad there's not that many
pages in this site this would get
ridiculous to to try to manage if it was
a really large site I'm gonna I'm gonna
have to think of some other way to
manage this when I try to apply this to
a larger site all right we have
Franciscan in the time there we go
and here's art here's our length
and let's put it there I'm going to keep
the same title there because it
basically works it's taking them to some
information about princess getting them
alright great
and that should have hot reloaded no
that's because that's the live site
let's go back here courses and yep that
works that I'm going to try to go there
alright it works
always test your links out at some point
you never know if you might have messed
something up accidentally and you got a
broken link because he copy/pasted wrong
if you watch my previous videos copy and
paste errors are real and they can mess
up your day so alright everybody I'm
that I'm going to save everything from
this live chat and I will go through it
at some point I just don't have time
right now so if you're something that
you asked me that I didn't get to that
you really wanted to ask me or something
that you wanted to tell me that would be
helpful that I didn't see put it in a
comment on this video uh and then I'll
definitely see it I'll read this chat
too so I guess I'll see it eventually
but if you put in a comment I can
respond back to it thanks for sticking
around for a long time we still have 17
viewers after two and a half hours which
is which is great probably not too many
people stay the whole time but hopefully
you you learn picked up something useful
or at least got an idea of you know how
things are on launch day at times it's
not always this crazy on launch day I
usually have more time and things
running a lot more smoothly but when
you're on a tight schedule this is kind
of how it works so I'm gonna go now um
I'll probably do a livestream tomorrow I
don't really know what it'll be about I
guess it depends on how the site's
running and if there any extra work
needs done on it I'm gonna go now get
something to eat
I might start to stream again on my own
channel so you can check me out there
thanks for all the advice you all were
great and helped me find a lot of stuff
that would have taken me a lot longer to
find I really appreciate it
so I'll
either talk to you later today or
tomorrow